あのさ、aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
思ったんですけど前髪伸びるの早くない?aaaaaaaaaaaa
もう変でもないっしょｗ
(と、思いたいはじめであった。)
こんにちは!はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さんぬいぐるみ好きですか?
僕はー…そんなに好きではありません。
今回はクマのぬいぐるみを買ってきました。
こちら！！
うおいしょーっ！　ほっ。
はいこちら、「ヒミツのクマちゃん」です。
すげー、またなんか受賞してるな。凄い。
ヒミツのクマちゃん。
"みんながおどろく不思議なぬいぐるみ"
そう、これ凄いんすよ。
「おともだちになろうよ！」とクマちゃんが言っております。
こどもはぜったいにあけてはだめです。                            (ひらがな翻訳機能開始）
これまじちょっと…おれ…まじかこれ…。
Ah(あー)…これやばいな…。
いまみてるこどもたち
このなかみはちょっとこどもたちにはみせられないので
Yoo(よぅ)…あのー…こどもたち。
おとうさんおかあさんにこのどうがをみていいかきいてね。    パパやママにこのおどうがをみていいかきいてね
うん。
きいてよかったらみてもいいけど、
おとうさんおかあさんがダメっていったらもうみちゃダメだよ。
ダメだよ。
ホントにこのなかみはこう…ｵｽｨ…おしえられませんから。
5さいとか4さいのこどもたちは、
みちゃダメだぁ！！（迫真）
（ひらがな翻訳機能終了）
まあどっちでもいいんだけどね…。
ただこの中身を知りたくない人は見ないでね。
はい、ではいきますよー。
はーい！こんにちわんこそばと。
クマさんがいるんですけども。
なんとこちらがすごいんです。
これ凄いですよ。いろんな会話がね、できるんです。
クマが。
なんでもしゃべれるんですよ。
もう「おはよう」とか「はみがきしてね」とか何でも言えるんですけども、
ここから本当に秘密を守れる子供たちだけ見てね。
はいこちら。
トランシーバーで、お母さんが話しているんです。
クマがあたかもしゃべるようにして、
ちっちゃい子供たちだったらもうクマさんが本当にしゃべってると思って、
本当にマジでしゃべるぬいぐるみ。トランシーバー付きでございます。
では開けていきましょう。
よーし来た!
お前可愛いなぁ♪
でこっちがトランシーバーで
これで僕がしゃべるとこの子がしゃべると。
マイクに向かって話しかけます。
オッケー。
あ。
おま、え？
『こんにちは』
うえっ！？
『こん・にち・は』
『こんにちは ×2』
動くんだねぇ♪
ｳｩｩｩｩ↑
『あ、あ、あぁ。』(裏声)
ちょっと俺あっちの部屋行ってくる!
『こん・にち・は』
『ありがとうございます』
『ｵrrrrrrrr』
しゃべれる！
えーこれ凄くない!?これマジで!
これ凄いです!マジで多分しゃべりますちゃんと!
え!すごいなこれ!
というわけで今回は!この
しゃべるクマさんを使って、
ピザを注文してみようと思います。
もうピザの配達の人もきっとね。
いつも同じピザの注文。いつも同じ受け取り方。
つまんないと思うんすよ!
もっとこう、ロマンティック溢れる刺激的なピザの配達をしたいと思うので!
もうクマさんがピザを頼むって聞いただけでもう多分皆萌え死ぬと思うんで。
俺なら萌え死ぬよ♪
ではちょっとね、クマさんがピザを注文してみようと思います!
早速ピザ頼むｻﾞｧｰ!
(発信音)
ﾌﾌｯwww
あ、すみません、ちょっとピザを頼みたいんですけど。
『はい、お届けでしょうかお持ち帰りでしょうか。』
あ、お届けでお願いします。
『えー生地と生地の間にチーズが入っているミルフィーユというピザがございますが。』
はい、大丈夫です。
『ご注文は以上で宜しかったでしょうか?』
お気をつけて…。
『はい、ありがとうございます。』
ありがとうございます。
失礼します。
これ滅茶苦茶面白いなマジで!
はいというわけで!
今回はこのクマさんがピザを頼んで。
果たしてクマがピザを頼むと、
ピザを配達してくれた店員さんはどんな反応をするのか。
試してみたいと思います!
では行こう！
クマちゃんがいて、クマちゃんの下にはちゃんと
ピザ置き場が準備してあります。
『はい』
『ありがとうございまぁす。』
5000円。
2,022円置いておきます。
『はいありがとうございます。』
は～いすいませんありがとうございます。
『ありがとうございます。では、お気をつけて』
はい。
『ありがとうございます。』
は～い。
『ｶｼｬｯ』
『よし。』